how much
uh information do you think is required
to to be a house cat
so you have to be able to uh when you
see a box going it when you see a human
compute the most evil action if there's
a thing that's near an edge you knock it
off
all of that
plus the extra stuff you mentioned which
is a
great self-awareness of the physics of
your of your own body and in the world
how much knowledge is required do you
think to solve it
um i don't even know how to measure
an answer to that question i'm not sure
how to measure it but whatever it is it
fits in about
about 800 000 neurons
800 million neurons or the
representation does
everything all knowledge everything
right
um
it was less than a billion a dog is two
billion but a cat is less than one
billion
and uh
so multiply that by a thousand and you
get the number of synapses
uh and i think almost all of it is is
learned through this you know a sort of
cell supervised running although you
know i think a tiny sliver is run
through reinforcement running and
certainly very little through you know
classical supervised running although
it's not even clear how supervised
learning actually works in uh in a
biological world
um so i think almost all of it is uh is
self supervision but it's driven
by uh the the sort of ingrained
objective functions that a cat or human
have at the base of their brain which
kind of drives their
behavior so you know nature tells us
you're hungry
it doesn't tell us how to feed ourselves
that's that's something that the rest of
our brain has to figure out right
well it's interesting because there
might be more like deeper objective
functions underlying the whole thing so
hunger may be some kind of
now you go to like neurobiology it might
be just the brain
trying to maintain homeostasis
so hunger is just one of the
human perceivable
symptoms of the brain being unhappy with
the way things are currently right it
could be just like one really dumb
objective function at the core but
that's how that's how behavior is is
driven uh the the fact that you know the
orbital ganglia
drive us to do things that are that are
different from say no wong tong or
certainly a cat
is what makes you know human nature
versus orangutan nature versus scat
nature
so for example
uh you know our basal ganglia drives us
to
seek the company of uh other humans
and that's because nature has figured
out that we need to be social animals
for our species to survive and it's true
of many uh primates
it's not true of orangutans orangutans
are solitary animals
they don't seek the company of others in
fact they avoid them
in fact they scream at them when they
come too close because they're
territorial
because for for their
survival you know uh evolution that's
figured out that's the best thing
i mean they're occasionally social of
course for you know
reproduction and stuff like that but um
but but they're mostly solitary so
so all of those behaviors are not part
of intelligence you know people say oh
you're never going to have intelligent
machines because you know human
intelligence is social but then you look
at orangutans you look at octopus
octopus never know their parents
they barely interact with any other and
they and they get to be really smart in
less than less than a year in like half
a year
um
you know in a year they're adults in two
years they're dead so
um
there are things that we think
as humans are intimately linked with
intelligence like social interaction
like language
we think
i think we give way too much importance
to language as a substrate of
intelligence as humans
because we think our reasoning is so
linked with language so for to solve the
house cat intelligence problem you think
you could do it on a desert island you
could have pretty much you could just
have a cat sitting there
um
looking at the waves that the ocean
weighs and figure a lot of it out it
needs to have sort of you know the right
set of drives
uh to kind of
you know get it to do the thing and
learn the appropriate things right but
uh
like for example you know uh baby humans
are are driven to
learn to stand up and walk
okay you know it's not that's kind of
this desire is hardwired how to do it
precisely is not that's learned
but the desire to to walk move around
and stand up
uh that's sort of
hardwired it's very simple to hardwire
this kind of stuff
oh like the desire to well
that's interesting you're hardwired to
want to walk
that's not a
there's got to be a deeper need for
walking
i think it was probably socially imposed
by society that you need to walk all the
other bipedal
like a lot of simple animals that you
know would probably work without ever
watching any
other members of the species it seems
like a scary thing to have to do
because you suck it by peter walking at
first it seems crawling is much safer
much more
like why are you in a hurry
well because because you have this thing
that drives you to do it you know um
which is sort of part of uh the sort of
human development is that understood
actually what not entirely no what is th
what's the reason to get on two feet
it's really hard like most animals don't
get on two feet well they get on four
feet you know many mammals get on four
feet yeah they very quickly some of them
extremely quickly
but i don't you know like
from the last time i've interacted with
a table that's much more stable than a
thing then two legs it's just a really
hard problem yeah how many birds have
figured it out with two feet
well technically we can go into ontology
they have four
i guess they have two feet they have two
feet chickens
you know dinosaurs are two feet many of
them allegedly
i'm just now learning that t-rex was
eating grass not other animals t-rex
might have been a friendly
friendly pet
you